[Music]
alrighty so today i'm going to explain
what just happened with gamestop to put
it mildly it's been a wild ride for
gamestop which
at one point here has been valued at
more than delta airlines which is very
weird because gamestop for
people who have visited it is basically
a swap meet meets blockbuster for video
games
basically here's what happened so at the
beginning of january they had a change
in leadership and that caused some
optimism at the company
but some people thought that the
optimism was sort of overvalued at the
company
in hedge fund world so what happened is
all those hedge fund traders they short
sold the stock so i'm going to explain
what exactly happened and then
how a bunch of people on reddit
basically screwed
all of those hedge fund guys it's pretty
unbelievable we'll get to that in just
one second first i want to remind you
you need to check out expressvpn.com
shapiro to protect your online data if
you don't trust big tech now be an
excellent time to check out
expressvpn.com
shapiro so we first have to explain what
a short sale is for people who don't
actually know
what a short sale is so we have a couple
of players
in our short sale okay if you wanna if
you believe a value
is overpriced for a stock if you think
that a stock is overpriced then you
engage in what's called a short sale so
you can capture
the value of the overpricing here's how
it works you have a hedge fund guy we're
gonna call that guy bruce cause
everybody hates bruce right
so here's bruce okay so you got bruce
over a one month period
bruce believes that the stock of game
stop is going to drop
right this is this is one month
okay so what does bruce do he doesn't
own any stock
in gamestop because he doesn't like
gamestop he thinks that it's actually
not a company that is of great value
so what does bruce do he goes to a
broker right the broker
then proceeds to lend bruce the stock
okay the stock
is moving from the broker to bruce bruce
is going to borrow that stock
for a month then one month from now
bruce is going to give
that stock back to the broker plus some
sort of
percentage fee so let's just say that
bruce is going to give
the for the sake of easy math the broker
back the stock plus 10 bucks
so bruce in one month
is then going to reverse the transaction
he's going to return the stock
to the broker
plus 10 bucks okay now
bruce again he thinks that the stock is
overpriced right now so now bruce has
the stock
so what does bruce do let's say that the
stock price is
50 bucks for the sake of argument so
bruce then goes to the market
[Music]
and he is going to sell this stock
right he's going to sell the stock that
he has borrowed to the market
okay and bruce in return is going to
receive
bruce now has 50 in his pocket now the
month progresses bruce has no stock but
he has to return the stock back to the
broker so what does he do he waits for a
month
now because bruce was right the stock
price dropped so bruce can now buy the
stock
from the market right so the market is
now going to sell
the stock to bruce
and bruce it's let's say it's dropped to
20 bucks is going to pay 20
to the market so that means that bruce
sold the stock at 50
he bought the stock at 20 so that means
that he made
30 on that transaction then he has to
return the stock plus 10 bucks to the
broker
so now he has made 20 bucks on the
transaction right so here's what
everybody at the end of the day got from
that transaction
so the broker got
the stock plus 10 bucks and bruce ends
up clearing a profit
of 20 bucks after all that is said and
done okay that's what bruce is hoping
for
if the value of the stock has dropped
now
here's what the gamestop guys did
alrighty so before we get to more of
this i want to explain to you why you
should be using
expressvpn so expressvpn it's going to
protect your online data so your online
data it is vulnerable to hackers it is
vulnerable to your isps which can follow
you around
link your identity to all of the
websites that you visit and then
monetize all of that if you don't trust
big tech
you should definitely be protecting your
online data
with expressvpn it's really really easy
i've got it right here
on my cell phone all i have to do is go
over to my expressvpn app
just click one button right now it says
i am not connected but boom
i hit that and there it goes there it
goes i am now connected
this now means that i am protected okay
it is that simple it is not difficult to
do
and here is the thing it's not gonna
cost you a fortune either right now head
on over to expressvpn.com slash repair
you get the first
three months free when you get that
one-year package head on over to
expressvpn.com
shapiro today protect yourself from the
predations of big tech go check out
expressvpn.com
shapiro to get started it's as easy as
one poke on your phone
so on reddit there's a reddit thread
called wall street bets
and they noticed that there were a lot
of bruises and all the bruises were
short selling the stock
all the bruises were basically betting
that they were going to be paying back
the broker the stock
right now but they don't actually have
the stock right they haven't actually
bought the stock yet
right they're planning on buying the
stock right before they sell it back
to the broker so they don't have the
stock so what do
the subreddit guys do what the subreddit
guys do is they say okay what if we just
bruise what if what what if what we
actually do here
is drive up the price of the stock right
so now
when bruce let's say he sells it for 50
bucks because he thinks it's gonna be
down at 20 a month from now
now the month has passed right we're now
in this period
so the reddit guys what do they do they
say we are going to
artificially boost the price of the
stock because all of us are going to get
together we're going to buy up all the
stock that exists
in gamestop we're going to buy like all
of it and so the price
is not going to be 20 for bruce to
actually
buy the stocks that he can pay back the
broker instead the stock is going to be
200 right so now bruce is
really screwed because bruce sold the
stock for 50 but now he has to buy the
stock
for 200. so that means that bruce is no
longer up 20 bucks
now bruce is down
160 bucks right so that is what they are
doing in short they are they are
basically screwing bruce beyond belief
by artificially boosting the price of
the stock now here's the thing
they're not taking into account the
market fundamentals they don't care
about the market fundamentals they don't
care the game stop
actually is not worth 200 bucks in terms
of the stock
so what does that mean this means that
this only works and this can only
continue so long as the price of the
stock remains high
because once the price of the stock
begins to drop if he continues to buy
short sales
then as the price of the stock drops you
go back to your original calculation
right if the price of the stock goes
back down to 20 bucks then bruce is okay
you can still buy all of the stock back
so they can keep screwing bruce for as
long as possible just by holding the
stock and that's why you're seeing
things like
hold the line do not sell trending on
twitter because all these reddit guys
are like the longer we do this the more
the hedge fund guys get screwed because
what the hedge fund guys are doing in
order to combat the fact that they're
losing money
on each one of these deals is number one
they have to buy the stock in order to
pay back
the broker or at least they have to pay
the broker some money and two
they realize that at a certain point
this is gonna give way because all the
people who bought all the reddit guys
who bought
eventually they're gonna realize oh hold
up a second i can make a lot of money by
selling the stock right now
right that will drop the stock price
eventually but i will clear
this giant profit in the meantime so
what the big hedge fund guys are doing
is they are betting even more into short
right they're saying okay for sure the
stock is going to drop we know it's
going to drop it's just a matter of time
for it to drop
so what they are actually doing is
creating more of an impetus
for people to continue buying the stock
and setting the stock price higher
because the more that they short squeeze
the short squeeze the more they short
squeeze the brokers the more
that the brokers are going to have to
pay in order to in order to fulfill the
promises that they have made
to the brokers in the first place the
more bruce's they screw the more money
they can make but that only holds true
so long as you can hold the line so long
as there's a collective action
not to just sell right now and drop the
price of the stock
so that is what is going on right now in
the midst of all of this
a bunch of tech companies have decided
they don't like
what the what the reddit guys are doing
they don't like that the reddit guys are
screwing the bruce guys
and there are a couple reasons they're
saying this one is they're saying that
the reddit guys they don't care about
the underlying value of the stock they
don't care about the fact that they are
now trading the stock in multiple times
what it actually is probably worth
what they really care about is screwing
the bruces of the world and this is
screwing up the market mechanism
so that's kind of a that's a somewhat
fair criticism the other thing that they
don't like
is they don't like the people getting
screwed they don't like that it's the
hedge fund guys that they normally trade
with who are getting screwed so what
you've seen
is places like robin hood say we're not
going to allow you to continue to buy up
the stock and continue to artificially
inflate
the price of the stock right you're
seeing other
places take down subreddit boards right
the subreddit board was
actually taken down the folks who did
that said it was to ban hate speech it
was not the ban hate speech it was not
the ban violent speech it was
specifically done
in order to undercut the market for
gamestop stock it was deliberately done
in order to create
a sellable market so people would start
selling their stock immediately and the
price would go back down and people
would stop getting screwed over
in bruce world okay so that's exactly
what's going on with gamestop right now
you can be on either side of that you
can be on either side of that you have
to admit that this
is legitimately one of the funniest
things that has ever happened in the
history of wall street